mali isn't doing too well says
maiga gibril a doctor trained in the
former soviet union he believes
russia not france or the u.n forces can
heal the country from war
when france came to my country they were
welcomed as liberators
now they have turned into invaders we
want russia
to come clean up our country and bring
the war to an end
russia needs african nations too at the
moment
it's as if it's the cold war again in
2013 malians were waving
french flags as the french military
intervened to stop
armed groups from marching towards the
capital but eight years on
half a million millions have been
displaced and nearly six thousand killed
as
armed groups intensify their attacks the
malian army
is on the retreat despite the support of
four thousand french troops
and fourteen thousand u.n peacekeepers
at the nation's independence square
same colors but different flag the
support for russia comes
from a feeling of frustration about the
deteriorating security situation
a sense from a part of the million
population that the
french military presence is not a
solution but perhaps part of the problem
it's also a show of support for the
military
and says bloodless coup last week
military regent leader colonel asimi
goyta put the president in pm under
house arrest last week alleging he had
proof that a foreign power was
interfering in the country's domestic
affairs
the coup happened after the ousted
transition leaders removed two cabinet
members
nominated by the military days after a
meeting with french president emmanuel
macron
the russian trained minister of security
colonel modibukuni and the minister of
defense sajo kamara
both sought greater cooperation with
moscow
the pro-russian sentiment is a fallout
of the anti-french sentiment because
malians are increasingly aware of a
growing rivalry between the two
countries in africa
but mali has to focus on malians with
france temporarily suspending military
cooperation with malian forces
until there is a return to a
civilian-led transition
dr mayga fears without the help of a
military power
mali will suffer even more
nick it's not just mali that's becoming
a bit of a tug of war when it comes to
foreign powers i see the russians have
also been fairly active in car for some
time now is that
setting a model for the region
well it seems like it and certainly the
french have been reacting towards it
just just today there was an
announcement made by the french
defense ministry suspending its
budgetary aid
and military cooperation with the
central african republic's government
accusing it of being complicit in a
campaign of
anti-french sentiment they say backed
by russia so make no mistake um the
the region whether it be in the central
african republic or in mali
has become a ground of a tug of inf
of a war of influence between russia and
the west more specifically
with with france and now this suspension
of military cooperation means that
some of the uh french adviser advisers
that are embedded
inside the the government of president
twitter
will return back to paris the 12 million
dollars
aid package to to the country has been
suspended
but this will have little effect to the
government in benghy
who heavily relies on the the russians
both for its
uh military aid and also for
uh other uh government aid um now what's
interesting is
it seems that this model that's been
seen
at this in central african republic is
appealing to
a portion of the public in mali not just
that
a portion of members of the the ruling
military junta
right now that are at the head of mali
there's also facebook that has
um removed accounts linked both to the
russian
enter france in mali and in the central
african republic
interesting dynamics indeed there
nicholas hack across all that for us
from dhaka thanks so much nick